I guess it was the right time people put
a judge putting his heart hat on and
transporting himself to East Palestine
Ohio three weeks after a Train derailed
and spewed toxic chemicals everywhere
the transportation secretary said he
would be all action once he arrived but
turns out he was all excuses
the country should be wrapping their
arms around the people of East Palestine
not as a political football
that is an ideological flap flash point
not as a gotcha moment I think that
includes visits not just big official
visits from the government I'm here for
the work and not for the politics you
can sense when you talk to local leaders
and local residents that they're getting
pretty sick of the politics too so I
think
so I lost my train of thought
um in hindsight with that waiting too
long to express anything hours after you
had addressed the makeup of work Crews
on Highway construction projects just
that very day the answer to your
question is yes I felt strongly about
this and could have expressed that
sooner wow mayor Pete's delayed trip
comes as a national Transportation
safety board released their preliminary
report it found the derailment was
likely caused by an overheated wheel
bearing and that the crew crew tried to
slow the train moments before it
derailed okay
um I'm going to start with you uh peers
I mean the truth is that here we've got
a Secretary of Transportation he's
saying he's there at the right time it's
all action uh how does that strike you
he said he lost his train of thought he
lost his thought about the train three
weeks ago let's be clear another quote I
read one senior Democrat who wanted to
remain anonymous as they always do Peter
has taken a lot of bullets for the
president on this one really because it
looks to me like Pete butterjudge who's
the transport secretary probably should
have gone down there three weeks ago
when this first happened and that the
only bullet that's been flying around is
metaphorically into himself at any
chance he now has of becoming president
of the United States because he was
Billy one of the people that was being
mooted to be a potential presidential
candidate but how can you be when this
happens on your watch your job is
transportation in America you have a
derailment where you have this town of
people who are absolutely gripped in
Terror about the repercussions of all
this toxic stuff going out into their
community and for three weeks you you
stay where you are and say I'm planning
to go and then Donald Trump goes down
Coles all your Bluffs goes down and does
the right thing even though he's no
longer the president and then the next
day Buddha judge goes down and Trump
says quite rightly what he's only gone
because I went down I think that's true
and I think it's embarrassing I think
like I said it's pathetic and if he had
actually any honor he'd probably Stand
Down from his job because if you can't
turn up when this thing happens why are
you a transport secretary well you know
Jesse that he's taking the position that
he's really the victim here that he's
taking the bullets for the president I
mean that's what they're saying when in
truth even Biden said Pete wasn't ready
for the job when they were running in
2020.
well Biden's Smart in this sense is that
it's never Biden's fault he puts these
people out there and then he hides and
then they take all the arrows he does it
with Kamal in the Border he does it with
Pete in the train wreck you know I
remember during the Trump Administration
anything that happened in the country
was Trump's fault or it was the Trump
administration's fault but when you have
a Democratic president who spends all of
his time hiding in Delaware his cabinet
takes all the heat but I have to admit a
lot of this is about a photo op when
these politicians go there we get that
but he looks like he's a little kid
wearing his father's clothes yeah
exactly he looks like what is he 150
pounds wet
not even a size small construction vest
fits this guy it's draping off of him he
looks like he's wearing a costume and he
doesn't know what to do with his hands
he says that people need to go there and
wrap their arms around the people there
I didn't see him hug one person did you
guys see any tape of him hugging anybody
he looks confused like he wants to get
out of there and he's snuck in at 7am
Sneaky Pete didn't show up when
everybody knew he was going there comes
in before everybody wakes up or goes to
work and that's when he does his photo
op and hightails it out all right I want
you to listen to this Tyrus some this
sound from Joy Behar
I don't know
whatever vote for him
who ties to the chemical industry in
charge of the epa's chemical safety
office that's who you voted for in that
District Donald Trump who reduces all
safety
what's your reaction to that how other
than the fact that no sane person
watches this how are they allowed to
continue to say the things that they say
so it's their fault it's their fault
it's disgusting sonny can call Nikki
Haley a chameleon and racist comments
and they just seem to get away with it
and they say these things the let's not
forget and the fact you lost your train
of thought Pierce you poor choice of
words say anything else but you lost
your train of thought three you're too
late you're three weeks too late they've
already started working the biggest
complaint that you're hearing now from
them is that the work's getting started
and they they don't want them the media
now it's like you missed your
opportunity if you cared you would have
been down there I'll tell you why he
wasn't going to go down there because he
didn't think it was safe okay that's why
he wasn't down he waited it out and it
wasn't what they considered we've seen
in this Administration I've said it a
lot on the on the Gutfeld show it seems
like they're fine with breaking a few
eggs when it comes to lower middle class
in this country with crime with
education I always just a few eggs got
broke just a few people got broke and so
it's not a big deal this will all go
away and my hat's off to not just Fox to
social media for keeping this story
alive and not letting this just slide
off into the back pages and no one
paying attention because here's the
other thing and where where are where
are the green people where is this is
going to be in the soil for decades you
know this is not going to go away
where's Greta Stromberg now come cry
over here and get some national
attention and get some help oh because
of quote who they voted for you I would
say shame on her but she has no shame
she's a disgusting person for for saying
comments like that and and that's just
complete irresponsibility yeah the shame
of it uh Dana is that we've got Kareem
Jean-Pierre who is uh condemning the bad
faith attacks on Buddha judge and and
the truth is he waited almost three
weeks tomorrow would be three weeks what
did he do he said he was planning it all
out first of all we know that's not the
case he didn't know about it he didn't
comment on it until people started
razzing him on social media but Omar
ilhan Omar that's who tweeted about it
when they're like oh we better pay
attention now this is a very rare event
where you have a disaster like this
that's getting more attention on the
third week since it happened than it did
in the first week since it happened and
they deserve the the media attention
um and all the thing about going in at
7am and what we didn't show you there
was a couple times there where the
cameras are following along and he's mad
right but when you are three weeks late
you just take your lumps they know you
have to know like we're not going to be
able to fight back enough to get to zero
but what do you what you should do in a
disaster and anybody that has good
instincts would know this is first you
do the right thing and then you figure
out the politics from there if you have
to but they didn't do that first part so
now they're trying to catch up and I
think a lot of their
um when they sound so defensive they
they could take some lessons from Alex
Murdoch who was there being like calm
cool and collected you're right you know
what you're right yep
you caught me you're exactly right what
can I do now I'm having advice from a
serial killer you should probably not be
transports
take advice I went on Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now